hi I'm Pierce Brosnan I'd like to talk
about some of the roles that I've played
in my life
iconic characters
James Bond
thank you mister my name is Bond
James Bond for me it was trying to walk
a line between Roger and Sean Connery
and not being shy of taking from their
work I was so enamored by Sean Connery
who I'd seen as a boy of 11 years of age
in Goldfinger and I watched him
transcend to the heady Heights of being
Bond and creating such an iconic
character oh no you don't
oh this is no time to be rescued
then came Roger and I watched Roger
portray the character
so I took from both men really I allowed
myself the grace to be able to try and
get the sense of humor that both men
brought to the part you destroy every
View
ER operating procedure no you get
chipped you get nicked you pull muscles
you get stitched up so I mean I I have
the greatest admiration for for Daniel
Craig and what he did the physicality
that he brought to the performance was
was Monumental you kind of have your own
private work that you deal with as an
actor in trying to portray this man it's
pretty overwhelming and then providing
your own truthfulness can you make a
truthful moment out of this scene
Mrs Doubtfire
I remember getting the job I remember
being absolutely over the Moon by
getting a job because I had to pay the
mortgage that month if I remember I was
a single father and I get a job with
Robin Williams this must be the famous
Mrs Doubtfire it's a pleasure to meet
you
yes well blah Miranda's been raving
about you odd she's never mentioned you
it's one of the Great great
clowns greatest comedian actor
humanitarian he led with his heart and
his soul and every fiber of his being I
was uh so thrilled to be working with
him Sally Field I remember going up to
San Francisco the first day I went into
the makeup trailer and Robin was there
he had a Hawaiian shirt on and big hairy
arms and cargo pants and
Airy legs and but he had the head of Mrs
Doubtfire oh hello Pierce oh you're very
handsome oh give us a kiss hey there
buddy as you see it ledge came up hello
Robin how are you man oh I'm good man
I've been here for hours it's a pretty
impressive bubble you got her oh thank
you thank you
who gives a gift like that he wants more
than a piece of her heart to eat
a bit of a going down payment huh
excuse me
sink the sub
hide the weasel Park the purpose a bit
of the old Humpty Dumpty I would go to
work and I went to work every day on
that movie and I was always working with
you know Mrs Doubtfire it wasn't till
the end of the movie that I met Robin
Chris Columbus is a director he created
such a warm environment for us all to be
free and creating and Robin of course
had full realm of creativity and
spontaneity and humanity and passion for
all of us as actors his commitment to
that role was phenomenal because he
would go to work and be there from four
o'clock in the morning oh isn't he a
stunning piece of work look nebby let's
call liposuction hmm
foreign
God knows what happened ah there's a
sunny morning and my character Stu has
to walk out on the diving board and do a
swallow dive
I don't dive I don't do swallow Dives
and I don't like heights top board 300
extras action I'd walk out to the end of
the board and I'd go like this and
they'd say cut and then I had to tiptoe
back
such humiliation
but it gave everyone a laugh so that was
that morning and then the next scene was
drive by fruiting
oh sir
I saw it
some angry member of the kitchen staff
did you not tip them oh the terrorists
they ran that way it was a run by
fruiting I'll get them so don't worry
try buy fruiting it wasn't in the script
I get the beers I'm walking back I'm
thinking this is going to take forever
forever to hit me on the head first one
missed
second one is history
Dante's Peak
oh god oh my god oh no
my mum calls me up and says Dante's Peak
is on again she lets me know back from
London all the movies that they play for
me as a boy growing up in in England
Sunday lunch then you'll watch a movie
so for her to be telling me that I'm on
TV just as a certain sense of
accomplishment and that's what you live
for the appreciation of the work and
that you bring joy to people's lives
turn them on don't they speak Roger
Donaldson good friend
great director offered me the role I
just love the title sometimes the title
will speak to you and
an instant
ly
it had the potential to be a crowd
pleaser
family film there's no deep
characterization of the man I knew that
I had a following and I had an audience
now as James Bond and I try to keep it
as simple as possible
within the context of the script and the
emotion of the script and the
relationships of the characters you know
I looked at film I looked at lots of
footage of these men who go into these
powerfully dangerous situations with
Mother Earth then I just had a great
time doing it fishing
I'll go fishing we were in Quarter Lane
you know some of these shots would take
a long time to set up so I get to work
at six seven in the morning and
sometimes I wouldn't see the camera
until about 10 11 or 12 but we'd be in
beautiful circumstances with a river so
I'd go fly fishing I mean that's where
my singing career started
because I sing row row row the boat
[Music]
then came Mamma Mia
not much progression there
Mamma Mia
we're here for the wedding I'm Bill
Anderson
I'm bright Harry bright Sam Carmichael
you are expecting us Mamma Mia Mamma Mia
is the gift that keeps giving it's just
one of those joyful memories of life my
father had just passed away my
stepfather and he was a Scotsman
Carmichael Bill Carmichael and I said
dad has to have the piper we have to get
bagpipes and as we're having this
conversation and having a little whiskey
it's just the Undertaker my mother and I
the phone rings and it's uh CAA my
agents they said you got a job I said
really oh Meryl Streep I went you're
kidding and they said look you have to
you're going to be in London we'd like
you to go see the production but we were
watching the production and my daughter
she said Daddy who are you playing I
said I don't know I forgot to ask I'm
one of the dads I you know the the gay
dad came on I could play him the butch
dad came on I could play him and then
Sam Carmichael came on the handsome dad
and
I could play him too and then in the
scene he says you've still got my
bagpipes
and his name is Carmichael so there you
go whatever that story means there was
some beauty to it
[Applause]
[Music]
it was terrifying having to do these
songs and you know SOS is is such a war
horse of a song I think what gave me the
greatest Comfort on the day of recording
the songs up at air Studios was to see
stellen and Colin looking like you know
rabbits caught in the headlights they
were terrified we were all terrified
having to sing we go into the studio
it's 10 o'clock in the morning it's air
Studios and there's Benny and Beyond
sitting at the piano all right boys
let's go
straight into the songs once we got that
out of the way the rest was just
becoming a company Philadelphia Lloyd
who directed Mamma Mia comes from the
theater comes from Opera so she created
a company we went down to Pinewood
Studios for about four or five weeks and
we rehearsed and in doing so you know
you're in a big Studio space and you
have to get out and dance and remember
the moves and you're making ass of
yourself and there was Merrell with us
all doing it and trying to remember the
dialogue or the steps so that gave us a
great confidence so when it became time
to film it
everyone was very secure
Madeline
well the movie Evelyn I made with my
producing partner my late producing
partner Beau Marie Sinclair and I we
created a company called Irish dream
time and in the space of 10 years we
made 10 movies Evelyn is one of those
films Paul Pender wrote the script based
on a true events of Desmond Doyle the
wife leaves him one Christmas morning
and he's left with children and as was
the want in those days the church and
the state had full manipulation and
control over the Dominion of society and
they took the children away from him
because he was a single parent he fought
to get his children back the spcc
the society for the Prevention of
Cruelty to Children Ah that's correct is
that [ __ ] part of the boat that I've
been included
no no
we only had the children's world first
time to lose a mother such a young age
can have a deeply traumatized effect how
is that any business of yours so much of
the work is an actor in the preparation
of the work as an actor is so interior
it's you sitting in your living room in
your bathroom walking the streets living
and if the story connects to your heart
and the writing sustains your
imagination that interior mechanism of
imagination and trying to create a look
can sometimes have some alchemy to it
for me it was the singing singing These
Pub songs I didn't have to be a great
singer but he was a singer with passion
[Music]
it was just a joyful film to make to be
back in Ireland to be in Dublin to be in
the cast that we had Alan Bates Stephen
Ray Aidan Quinn Juliana Margulies the
whole dynamic of the story was quite
powerful for its time that this man
should win against the church and the
state to bring back his children from
the the claws the the move of church and
state that Dynamic was there in its own
kind of reality and it's a film that I
cherish it's a film that I have a deep
kind of fondness for and it has a beauty
to it it is one that kind of will live
on the Shelf as a story for for someone
hopes many generations
Thomas Crown
so what do you think Crown you don't
have any regrets about the way you
played this do you regret
it's usually a waste of time
as is bloating
you figure out what you're going to say
to your board when they learned that you
paid me 30 million more than others were
offering
good morning gentlemen I love Steve
McQueen I love his work as an actor you
know you steal from the best You observe
how they do it how to be relaxed on
camera how to be present on camera you
know he was such a rough and rugged
character but the Crown Affair he was in
suits for the first time really and he
was playing this elegant role and he did
it brilliantly and what really turned me
on was The Windmills of Your Mind the
song and I love the romance of it so the
movies that I made with Irish dream time
and Bill Murray Saint Claire uh
definitely each and every one a haiku of
friendship and Beauty and the joy of
being able to make movies and to get
away with it and each one is dear they
don't have to be box office success or
just the accomplishment of making a
movie we went to the studio and they
said yes run with it I liked paint I
didn't want to steal money I didn't want
to steal diamonds I wanted to steal a
painting and I wanted to hit the mat
foreign
[Applause]
once we set sail with this and we had a
great script then it was the director
John mcteon and John and I had I had
made his first film out of the AFI film
called Nomads Leslie undown and myself
which is a little Thriller John went off
to be a mega director and I carried on
being an actor
foreign
sent us down to a dance studio in Times
Square we went down I don't know twice a
week we learned every different dance
you could possibly learn and really
learned them and then the day we came to
shoot that scene she was really nervous
I was nervous I was like oh my God here
we go
just go through the moves let's go
through the moves and we found ourselves
in some cupboard or some cubby Hill
going do
om he said have you seen the dress I
have to wear so she said it fits into
this matchbook I said don't worry you're
gonna be great don't worry
it's fine and then we went for the take
and we went out there and she was in
this dress this kind of gossamer
featherweight beautiful dress and like
300 extras cameras coming in and John
said just make it up
oh okay the lights came on and that's
what you see in the movie we just played
to Roman Polanski said no no it's not
about Tony Blair but all roads led to
Tony Blair
so I watched Tony Blair I looked at his
interviews and his performances as
the Prime Minister and it was so well
written the book had a great muscularity
to it of Storytelling Roman Polanski one
of the Great
directors of Cinema Mike would never
believe such crap he was too clever too
loyal Mike betrayed you to reichardt
how do you know that you tell me
record
he's lying
his phone number on the back of the
photograph
that's right cars
the handwriting
that's mccarrus
Mike
I'm based it on Tony Blair he was an
actor
who's a great actor great performer he
had great speech writers my particular
character in the movie that is but he
was fractured weak
insecure
fraud really
I had done not very good things by
his standards and practice of being a
prime minister
Black Adam
it's a massive character
it's never been portrayed on film before
us 40 years old in the making Jama the
director allowed us to have those Quiet
Moments oldest Hodge who plays Hawkman
and I are friends through many
incarnations of life so it's about
friendship it's about love and respect
for another man in a situation and you
have the power Dr Fate has the helmet of
Nabu which
a curse and a blessing because he
is Shackled to the power of the helmet
it's an addiction it's a curse it all
sounds a lot of frou-frou when you talk
about it like that but it's stuff that
you have to lend your heart to if you go
into the mythology of it whether it be
Dr Fate or James Bond you know I'm not
very good at articulating the inner
dialogue that one has otherwise people
think you're crazy but if it's really
well written you follow the you follow
the score you bring your own life to it
you bring you your own heart your own
feelings your own emotions yeah just big
characters big heroic characters but you
know if you had the courage to keep it
as simple as you possibly can and listen
and play it for all it's worth
and you have a good director who can
guide you and you can come up with
something that's really meaningful and
Powerful